تطورات لافته في مجريات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا خلال الساعات الماضيه ميزتها
حاله استهداف متزامنه لمنشات البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه فقد اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه في كييف ان هجوم الروسيه بصوارخ
باليسيا او صواريخ اس 300 استهدف منشات
كهرباء في العاصمه الاخرانيه مما ترى
سكانها للاحتماء بمترو الانفاق وحتى رئيس
البلديه السكان على البقاء في الملاجه على
اثر ذلك اعلنت شركه الكهرباء الاوكرانيه
وانها تعاني عجزا تسببت فيه هجمات سابقا
وفرضت حالات قطع طارئه للتيار الكهربائي
في كياب والمناطق المحيطه بها وقالت
الشركه ان عمالها يسابقون الزمن لاصلاح
الاضرار وفي مدينه الفيف غربا حذرت
السلطات من امكانيه انقطاع امدادات المياه
والكهرباء بعد ضربتين صاروخيتين على منشات
البنيه التحتيه اما في خارجا فقال عمده
المدينه ان القوات الروسيه استهدفه
المدينه باربعه صواريخ من ط بس 300 وان
القذف شامله البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه الصناعيه واعلن
فرد قطع طارق للتيار الكهربائي بعد ضربتين
على منشات حيويه